[Aplausos]
[Música]
brasil es el país del futuro y parece
que lo seguirá siendo para siempre
últimamente se habla mucho de los
escándalos de corrupción en este país de
la crisis por la que está pasando o de
la violencia urbana en muchas ciudades
como río de janeiro pero hay otro
aspecto muy característico de brasil del
que no se suele hablar tanto en los
medios de comunicación hablamos del país
más caro de toda latinoamérica
[Música]
tal cual como lo oís si queréis iros de
compras en una ciudad como sao paulo o
río de janeiro ya podéis ir preparando
la cartera porque os puede salir tan
caro como nueva york o londres incluso
los propios brasileños tienen una
palabra para esto lo llaman el justo
brasil algo así como un sobrecoste que
hay que pagar por el mero hecho de vivir
en el país de la samba y los carnavales
[Música]
vamos a tomar como ejemplo la
hamburguesa big mac que nos tomamos en
un mcdonald's los que lleváis tiempo
suscritos a visual político ya sabéis
que el llamado índice big mac se utiliza
en economía como precio de referencia
para medir el coste de vida de un país
un big buck es un bigmac pero lo llaman
por ejemplo en suiza que es uno de los
países más ricos del mundo el 'big mac'
nos costaría el equivalente a 675
dólares sin embargo en perú que es un
país más pobre nos saldría por 3 con 23
dólares tiene lógica verdad a fin de
cuentas el sueldo medio que cobra un
suizo es muy superior al de un peruano
[Música]
pues bien en brasil este bigmac nos
costaría 510 dólares es decir es mucho
más caro que otros países como reino
unido canadá o dinamarca según la web ex
patishtán puntocom sao paulo es la
ciudad más cara de toda américa del sur
con unos precios muy parecidos a los de
otras ciudades como houston en eeuu o
berlín en alemania
[Música]
y os preguntaréis cuánto ganan los
brasileños para poderse permitir este
coste de vida son más ricos que los
colombianos o los chilenos lo cierto es
que no el salario medio en brasil no
llega a los 600 dólares mensuales sin ir
más lejos los argentinos o los chilenos
tienen sueldos más generosos así que la
pregunta es por qué brasil es tan caro
cuáles son las razones que explican que
un país de renta media tenga unos
precios de país rico hoy vamos a
responder a esta pregunta y creedme esto
explica en buena medida muchos de los
problemas que han llevado a brasil a la
crisis que está sufriendo estos días
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
una economía aislada del exterior muchos
pensaréis que brasil es un país abierto
al comercio internacional verdad
y también de cuentas muchas empresas
internacionales como el banco santander
o telefónica tienen presencia en este
país desde hace años sin embargo brasil
tiene los aranceles más altos de toda
latinoamérica y esto qué significa pues
bien imaginad que tenemos una empresa
que fabrica teléfonos móviles en eeuu y
queremos vender en el mercado brasileño
pues bien por el mero hecho de vender un
producto hecho en otro país tenemos que
pagar un impuesto especial que puede
superar el 35 por ciento del precio de
mercado y como os podéis imaginar este
tipo de políticas tienen consecuencias
muy claras para los ciudadanos
[Música]
sintiéndose en marcha del mercado
brasileño debido a los altos aranceles
tal cual como lo oís durante varios años
los brasileños que querían comprarse una
wii o una nintendo ds tenían que viajar
a uruguay para encontrarla curiosamente
esto supuso una ventaja fenomenal para
sus competidores sobre todo microsoft y
su xbox sabéis por qué pues porque
microsoft tiene una planta en brasil
donde fabrica la xbox one es decir que
no la tiene que importar
[Música]
y ya sé lo que estáis pensando que poner
aranceles altos está muy bien porque
obliga a las empresas extranjeras a
poner fábricas en el país y dar trabajo
a los ciudadanos verdad pues realmente
no es así pensadlo bien cuando microsoft
monta una fábrica en brasil necesita
importar las máquinas con las que se
ensamblan los componentes se cortan los
plásticos etcétera y muchas de esas
máquinas vienen de otros países lo que
significa que tienen que pagar un
impuesto especial y al final son mucho
más caras que si la fábrica estuviera en
otro país con menos aranceles
[Música]
y quien paga ese sobrecosto
efectivamente el consumidor final eso
explica que incluso muchos productos
fabricados en brasil como por ejemplo
algunos modelos de volkswagen sean
extremadamente caros
para que os hagáis una idea si compráis
un volkswagen golf en ciudad de méxico
os costaría unos 15.000 dólares de eeuu
mientras que en sao paulo tendríais que
apoquinar más de 25 mil y todo esto pese
a que este modelo de coche concretamente
está fabricado en las afueras del mismo
sao paulo
pero espera de un momento porque esta no
es la única razón que explica este gusto
brasil
[Música]
el gusto logístico imaginad un
agricultor que cultiva soja en el estado
de pará al norte del país si quiere
transportar un cargamento para venderlo
en sao paulo debería enviarlo en un
camión y pasar por la autopista br 163
pues bien de los 1000 kilómetros que
tiene esta carretera 100 no tienen ni
siquiera alquitrán basta con que un día
llueva para que los camiones no puedan
pasar o se queden hundidos en el fango
pero éste sólo es un ejemplo más
lo cierto es que brasil tiene una de las
peores infraestructuras del mundo
incluso un país como la india tiene
mejores carreteras para que os hagáis
una idea cada vez que una agricultura
estadounidense bien de 100 dólares de
soja se tiene que gastar 9 en costes de
transporte ese mismo agricultor en
brasil tendría que gastarse 25 dólares y
a falta de carreteras los brasileños
invierten en camiones que a menudo se
estropean y encarecen aún más los costes
[Música]
lógicamente todo esto también se traduce
en precios más altos para todos los
bienes que se venden en brasil y os
preguntaréis por qué el gobierno de
brasil no invierte en infraestructuras a
fin de cuentas tienen empresas punteras
como el grupo odebrecht seguro que todos
los que veáis este vídeo desde
latinoamérica os sonará el nombre
odebrecht era la empresa de
construcciones y de ingeniería más
grande de toda la región
y digo era porque después de
protagonizar el mayor escándalo de
corrupción de la historia de todo el
continente es difícil saber lo que va a
pasar con esta empresa y esto explica en
parte porque brasil tiene unas
infraestructuras tan cochambrosas a fin
de cuentas buena parte del dinero se va
en sobornos y tráfico de influencias
pero no sólo eso cuál fue la brillante
idea del gobierno de brasil para
modernizar su país efectivamente juegos
olímpicos y mundiales de fútbol
hoy en día las grandes ciudades
brasileñas tienen unos preciosos
estadios con luces y tecnología puntera
sin embargo fuera de esas metrópolis nos
encontramos con ferrocarriles
abandonados autopistas sin asfaltar o
incluso barrios enteros que no tienen
una simple línea de autobús que les
conecte con la ciudad
las infraestructuras lamentables de
brasil cuestan a la economía nacional
más de 48 mil millones de dólares cada
año por supuesto que esto no solo tiene
consecuencias en los precios que pagan
los brasileños sino también en los que
pagamos en el resto del mundo por los
productos que se fabrican en brasil pero
de eso hablaremos en otro vídeo porque
ahora la pregunta que os estaréis
haciendo es como alguien que gana menos
de 600 dólares al mes se puede gastar 25
en comerse una pizza normal en un
restaurante de sao paulo ahora lo vamos
a ver
[Música]
y enganchados al crédito durante décadas
brasil tenía una de las inflaciones más
altas del mundo en los años 80 y 90
llegaron a superar el 6 mil por ciento
de tasa de inflación interanual para que
os hagáis una idea imaginad que en 1980
os tomáis una cerveza en un bar de río
de janeiro que esa cerveza os cuesta
vamos a decir 100 cruceros el crucero
era la divisa que usaban en aquella
época pues bien un año más tarde en el
mismo bar esa misma cerveza os costaría
600 mil cruceros
como os podéis imaginar esa
hiperinflación creó unos hábitos de
consumo muy distintos a los que tenemos
en el resto del mundo para sobrevivir
las tiendas brasileñas se acostumbraron
a vender productos a plazos y estas
estrategias continúan siendo muy útiles
en un país con unos precios tan altos
por eso todavía hoy podemos ver los
precios de las tiendas con un numerito
al lado que puede decir por 10 por 12 o
por 20 ese número y esa equis significa
que puedes pagar ese producto en 10 12 ó
20 plazos dicho de otra forma la
pregunta que se hacen muchos brasileños
no es si este traje o esta televisión es
cara o barata sino si podré pagar los
plazos en los próximos dos años y como
os podéis imaginar cuando pagas algo a
plazos te sale mucho más caro por
ejemplo aquí tenemos un smartphone en un
ecommerce brasileño
si os fijáis pagándolo de una sola vez
nos cuesta 632 reales que serían como
unos 200 dólares sin embargo pagando lo
a plazos nos costaría el equivalente a
217 dólares un 7% de diferencia que se
suma al resto de sobrecostes de los que
hemos hablado ya todo esto significa que
el brasileño medio está
continuamente pagando deudas y
lógicamente esto tiene sus consecuencias
cerca del 60% de los brasileños está en
deudas por los pagos aplazados pero
esperad un momento porque esto no es lo
peor de todo en los últimos años ha
aparecido un nuevo elemento que ha
elevado este costo brasil a unas cotas
verdaderamente nacho vidal ya nas
[Música]
en las tarjetas de crédito a principios
de los años 2000 brasil se convirtió en
la niña bonita de todos los bancos
grandes entidades como el santander o
credit suisse dispararon sus inversiones
en el país hablamos de un mercado con
más de 200 millones de habitantes que
estaba en pleno crecimiento y donde los
precios son altos y la población está
acostumbrada a consumir cosas pagando
las a plazos
[Música]
en otras palabras brasil era el lugar
perfecto para vender tarjetas de crédito
de dólares de 2005 el mercado de
tarjetas de crédito en brasil ha crecido
en más de un 20% cada año en el año 2012
los brasileños ya tenían una media de 2
tarjetas de crédito por persona y las
usaban como si no existiera mañana
brasil era el país que más dinero gasta
va en crédito per cápita de toda
latinoamérica sin embargo estas alegrías
durarían bastante poco en el año 2012
saltaron las alarmas en todos los bancos
del país
la morosidad en las tarjetas de crédito
de brasil alcanza un 27 por ciento en
abril de 2012 en un país en crisis donde
el desempleo crece y los sueldos bajan
es muy difícil devolver las deudas y qué
pasa cuando un banco tiene miedo de los
morosos efectivamente suben los tipos de
interés
[Música]
los brasileños tienen que pagar un
interés del
414 por ciento en sus tarjetas de
crédito imaginad que utilizamos la
tarjeta para comprar una televisión que
cuesta 1000 dólares y la pagamos en 12
plazos mensuales pues bien al final del
año sumando los intereses la televisión
nos habría costado cinco mil dólares
nuestra mal verdad y ojo que no se nos
olvide que el salario medio en brasil ni
siquiera llega a los 600 dólares al mes
en otras palabras que por muchas medidas
que se pongan para luchar contra la
pobreza la mayoría de los brasileños
viven en condiciones de subsistencia y
lo que es peor apenas pueden ahorrar
dinero con lo que se pierde en el
trabajo no tienen un colchón para poder
sobrevivir y eso explica noticias como
esta
de hecho en río de janeiro aumentan en
un 150 por ciento en sólo tres años
mientras tanto el presidente de brasil
michel temer está acusado por cargos de
corrupción y tiene la popularidad por
los suelos y por supuesto los anteriores
presidentes están igual o peor
si queréis conocer algo más sobre ese
escándalo de brecht que ha sumido a
brasil en el caos político haced clic en
este vídeo y ahora la pregunta es puede
brasil salir de esta situación quién
puede reformar el país podéis dejarme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios
como siempre no olvidéis que sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribiros al canal para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones
si os ha gustado este vídeo dadle a like
y nos vemos en el próximo un abrazo y
hasta pronto
[Música]